la gronde des propriétaires après les
propos polémiques de la ministre
déléguée au logement emmanuelle wargon a
déclenché une polémique le week-end
dernier après avoir affirmé que la
construction de maisons individuelles
était je cite un non sens écologique
économique et sociale
pourtant c'est un modèle est très prisé
des français la ministre déléguée du
logement est revenu depuis sur ses
propos elle a apporté quelques
précisions regarder
je ne souhaite pas mettre en cause la
maison individuelle la question c'est où
et comment on construit pour répondre
aux aspirations des français je n'ai
parlé que des pavillons en lotissement
la maison individuelle c'est un rêve des
français je le comprends ces
lotissements en trois conséquences que
les français connaissent d'une part la
désertification des entre des villes qui
n'ont plus de services plus de coiffeur
plus d'épicerie plus de café mais aussi
un sentiment d'isolement une perte de
lien social dans ces lotissements et
enfin la question du sort réservé à nos
terres agricoles puisqu'on en a perdu
25% depuis 1960 et on en parle tout de
suite avec jean marc sylvestre c'est les
vidéos etc ou de la matinale
g
bonjour jean marc bonjour ma gueule
ravine vont tomber dans cette matinale
d'arreter france avec cette question est
ce qu'on va devoir garder nos maisons
individuelles quelle mouche a piqué la
ministre du logement jean-marc devenir
ainsi critiqué un mode d'habitation qui
est plébiscité par à la majorité des
français oui je crois que c'est
effectivement elle était un peu à côté
de la plaque elle est peut-être née sous
le signe du scorpion puisque c'est le
voit du scorpion et donc c'est dans sa
nature que de piquer évidemment non mais
vous le disiez elle a été très brutal
parce qu'elle a dit et c'était officiel
en fait pour elle que la maison
individuelle était un non-sens
économique non sens écologique elle n'a
pas dit ça par hasard il ya un modèle
d'urbanisme qui est dépassé donc tout le
monde a compris que le logement
individuel était finie alors elle s'est
un peu reprise après vous l'avait cité
en s'apercevant que la pad de la panique
elle avait un peu créé lundi qu'elle
n'avait pas voulu attaquer ce mode
d'habitat qu'elle vivait qu'elle visait
des lotissements sait pas de quoi elle
parle exactement parce que toutes les
maisons individuelles sont un peu un
lotissement sauf qu'ils sont sauf celles
qui sont complètement isolés mais mais
en fait le mal était fait sur le terrain
politique la maison individuelle c'est
le mode d'habitation préféré et rêvait
de la grande majorité des français et ça
pas depuis hier un ca date au moins de
50 ans tout ça mais jean-marc pourquoi
at elle lâché cette petite bombe bas à
mon avis il ya beaucoup de raisons à
cela d'abord parce que je crois qu'elle
reproduit un peu le discours contient
dans son milieu social c'est un ministre
très compétent experts mais mais issu de
la classe des région parisienne son père
avait été ministre sous valéry giscard
d'estaing dans des années 70 des années
giscard lionel stoléru il s'appelait
mail sans doute elle a sans doute vécu
qu'entre l'appartement haussmannien à
paris et puis la grande maison de
famille à la campagne mais derrière ça
il ya un vrai réflexion sur l'avenir de
la maison individuelle ce mode d'habitat
s'est développée à partir des années
1960 parce qu'il offrait un prix plutôt
abordable un habitat dont rêvaient les
français c'est un habitat neuf avec le
confort du jardin je rappelle quand même
on sortait c'était les trente glorieuses
on sortait quand même de la deuxième
guerre une pelouse un barbecue le rêve
un ou deux garages parce qu'il fallait
aussi avec tout ça une ou deux voitures
puisque on était loin du sang des écoles
du travail c'est donc un habitat qui a
passionné l'urbanisme qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui or cet urbanisme là et bien
nous oblige où nous a obligés à
consommer beaucoup d'essence consommée
des services publics et puis il a
détruit beaucoup de centre-ville alors
dans les années 1960 il était totalement
voulue par le pouvoir totalement
encouragé par le pouvoir c'était le
président georges pompidou celui qui
avait succédé à général de gaulle qui
disait bas les français veulent de la
bagnole on va leur faire des bagnoles
ils veulent des autoroutes on va leur
faire des autoroutes il disait aussi ils
veulent des maisons eh bien faisons leur
des maisons il ajouta même quand on a
une maison eh bien on fait pas dray ont
fait pas la révolution ont fait très peu
de politiques on reste chez soi bah il
ce qu'on paie finalement parce que les
gilet jaune au départ back in fine est
quand même des pavillons individuels
par
la plus plus que plus de la moitié plus
de la moitié des logements et en france
37 millions de logements en gros la
moitié de ce sont des maisons
individuelles l'autre moitié ce sont
soit des appartements qui sont en
situation de ces logements sociaux
souvent à la périphérie des comptes
ville et vous alors soit des logements
un peu plus chic mais après inabordable
donc la situation actuelle elle est
bloquée parce que il nous manque en gros
150 à 200 mille logements par an les
prix sont devenus insupportables dans
les grandes villes ou alors née
logements sociaux sont introuvables
puisque ils sont surbookés donc la seule
solution pour pour pour les jeunes pour
les primo accédants comme on dit qui
veulent s'installer bas c'est d'aller à
l'extérieur dans la périphérie des
villes et même en campagne se payer une
heure ou deux de métro
c'est le moins cher bien sûr c'est sans
doute le plus confortable mais c'est
habiter la campagne et travailler en
ville font la voiture c'est obligatoire
avec une essence qui on le voit
aujourd'hui coûte de plus en plus cher
et ça va durer il est évident qu'il faut
entamer une réflexion là dessus on alors
quelles sont les solutions pas une
solution serait évidemment de construire
davantage on joue 10 150 à 200 mille
logements pour faire baisser les prix
mais on ne construit pas parce qu'il ya
pas de terrains à bâtir ya pas de permis
de construire les maires se méfie des
recours il bloque tous les mouvements
écolos aussi blog de leur côté ils sont
d'ailleurs un peu contradictoires ils
veulent un peu d'égalité du mieux vivre
mais il bloque les permis de construire
on s'étale il ya deux façons 1 ou alors
on s'étale ou alors on construire en
hauteur si on sait si on s'étale sa
demande d équipements de transport ou
alors si les transports publics on n'a
pas si on si on monte un étage par
exemple ce qui avait été un projet met
un étage de plus à paris un peu partout
on aime bien les propriétaires sont pas
chauds ils vivent un peu sur leurs rangs
plat de situation donc ils se protègent
non paris est une des seules métropole
au monde qui ne concevait pas en hauteur
qui serait pourtant la solution ou alors
à la défense mais ça c'est un problème
mais qui bâtit qui voulaient genre est
il beaucoup quand même aller à bika la
défense donc oui il ya une réflexion
c'est une réflexion qui ne détruira pas
d'un pavillon individuel sache faut pas
quand même pas exagérer quand on est
musulman on essaie de ne pas désespérer
ceux qui habitent les logements
notamment en périphérie le métier du
politique est quand même difficile à
exercer on le voit encore un mot et sans
être méchant emmanuelle wargon a fait un
livre en 2018 j'ai retrouvé ça s'appelle
bien venu en politique destiné à tous
ceux qui sont tentés de renoncer chez
calmann lévy on peut le trouver elle
l'avait fait pour tirer les leçons des
gilets jaunes je crois qu'ils devraient
relire
merci beaucoup jean-marc on va lire
aussi avec intérêt